So you remember this,
a slide from several lectures ago.
What are they trying to make?
Yeah.
Remember what the point
of this synthesis was?
This particular reaction,
the idea was to do a catalytic reaction
with something that was chiral as the
catalyst to do an oxidation on sulfur,
to make a single
enantiomers of a map result.
And remember the idea
was that the product,
after you've gone through these three
steps that we showed you before,
that the product then comes
back and is the catalyst again,
and you can do another cycle.
So in fact,
there's this thing
called a catalytic cycle.
So that what comes in is
a peroxide and disulfide,
and what comes out is an alk oxide
and the product that you want,
the oxidized product where an oxygen
has been added to that unshared pair,
that high homo.
And so the idea of the
chiral oxidizing agent was,
so you'd get a single in
anti more of the product.
But do you remember what happened?
Right. It gave her a simic material.
So what did they,
do you remember?
Pardon me?
Yeah.
Ethyl [inaudible] mean they added the,
these uh,
researchers I added in 2000 and they found
out that that gave a 94% in anti more
excess,
but for no obvious reason.
Now it would be great if we knew
what the reason for this was.
And it turned out that in fact this kind
of oxidative catalytic reaction to be
stereo specific to give a singly Nancy
or was the source of the Nobel Prize in
2001.
And if we click on this thing here,
we can see,
uh,
should see. Yeah, there we go.
So this is the Nobel website
and you can see that uh,
k Barry Sharpless here got the Nobel
prize in 2001 for his work on Kylie
catalyzed oxidation reactions.
So exactly this reaction.
So if anyone can tell us how,
uh,
how Ethel dice of purple of mean
does its trick, who should it be?
Barry Sharpless.
Right.
Okay, good. We can put this over here.
Y'All need this.
Put this in your pocket.
Clip this on your tie
there. We're all set. Thanks Mike.
I'd do anything for my friend Mike
because he saved me from publishing errors
in Jackson at least once.
And I just saved a lot of us who were
willing to listen to him because he's got
a genius for seeing flaws in,
in the beautiful stories
that people tell us.
And then they realized that
there beautiful stories
are going to be too slick,
usually in nature, doesn't like
things to be too slick. I, well,
I'm going to just use in, I think the
next slide you should be, let's see.
We need to go with this
first meeting to do this.
Is that,
is that it?
Oh, you want to get out to go back
through? Oh, you have that? Yeah. Okay.
There we go. Okay, great.
Well this is something which we
are possibly manipulate in utero.
I always,
it's interesting because many things
in our body like park can be on left or
right and uh,
it beer Emmy,
I assume that means they're mirror images
related then. But this, this is a vein,
two arteries that has the sheets on it
and it's the umbilical cord of a mammal
and it's got an ice screw access.
You know how we like to hold our
hand down a screw axis and uh,
and then I have another reasons why
I think that, that I handled it.
And then they take it away from you at
birth. They cut it and they take it away,
becomes the narcissistic
leak detected objects.
And that means you're in trouble
because you can't ever heal that wound.
You want to get back, but you can't heal
it. You needed that mirror, that boom,
boom, we're back there
when you were born. Anyway.
That's why I went crazy trying
to do asymmetrics synthesis. And
now you're a chemist, you know, you,
you, unless you're in deep space,
I don't know if they have
any carbon atoms out there,
but you've gotta be in a very high
vacuum to get them. But that's,
this is the way we make organic compounds,
right?
But we don't really do it this way because
we have to live in and convince phase
of the earth. So these are too high, but
you put them together, this is a point,
then you get aligned.
It's probably acetylene really.
But let me give me a poetic license of
just having it be a line and I'll take
one unit out.
And now if I add things across that line,
I get into the plane, uh, a and
B or I can add him CIS or trans.
In a sense,
you can make anything this way almost
if you could do it by just surgically
adding things.
Now we're in the plane and now the job
in the plane and I've actually drawn a
trans,
they substituted to beauty and I,
it has a shape like this, right?
It has a methyl group here, methyl
group here, and then hydrogen.
So there's open space in these quadrants.
And if you look at me
coming at you this way,
and if I turn around you
see it's going to be,
well, you'll see it's going to
be a mirror image situation.
But I'm flat so I have no
coyote. Uh, as a starting point,
I'm in the plane of the flat.
And so then if add hydrogen to it,
I get nothing interesting.
But if I add an Adam like
oxygen to it, like here, then I,
I parameter lies.
And so I can either add the oxygen from
my front and go like that puck side or I
can add it from my back.
And I go like that.
And that's the other mirror
image component. That's
a, it's a really cool way.
And it works.
You can make epoxides that way.
And we have regions today where you can
recognize the front and the back of a
flat object that has pro
Chi reality like this.
And back in the early and mid,
early seventies,
we saw this industrial
reaction that was nice.
You could take vanadium and Molybdenum
and you could park today's all the things
with these things called, uh, well I
don't have Darren's structure on it,
fortunately, but it's butyl
hydra peroxide. It's the, um,
it's the alcohol. It's the alcohol
group here with a peroxide bond.
I think you've already learned that
peroxide bonds, there are weak whys.
They have a, uh, a low
lying, a sigma star orbital,
and you're going to attack them on the
backside and transfer Adams to make a
transfer to carbon like Homo Olefin.
So what we noticed,
I noticed in one case that a
little like Alcoa halls, we're,
we're very much seem to be special.
It was just noticed by an
English chemist in the 30s,
that they seem to react better
than just normal alcohols. And so,
but nobody had taken, taken any, uh,
any really action on that.
And we should wait, wait,
you're not as fast as some people
and you're getting to this stuff.
So we should say that the now lily alcohol
is one that has an oxygen next to the,
on the carbon next to the
double bond. Oh yeah. Oh, great.
I forget the allelic alcohol
a little like means, uh,
a little your alpha one
Adam away from an orphan.
So what you could have anything,
their nitrogen, oxygen.
So you haven't always like an ethanol.
That's an a little like alcohol.
If there's a double, this isn't a look
alcohol. All right, where is it? I go,
I don't see, I don't, I'm sorry.
I don't have the right structures.
This is the allelic alcohol. It would
be, if I go back one, I'll show you.
Um, not by going forward. There's
the elbow like, oh yeah, I got one.
Like here,
this is a carbon.
That's the carbon that the Garmin
that by putting an o h group there,
that's a little like alcohol. If I have
another carbon, it's home. Although like,
but it has a handle now and that handle
allows it to grab hold of the vanadium.
Vanadium has all these alcohol. These
are esters. Imagine that's phosphorous.
It is like foster sexually
is, but it's the, it's a,
a yellow yellowish
liquid and it exchanges,
it's ligans like the wind with
alcohol. So they come in, they go out.
It's a real dance. It's fast. You don't
have to worry about that happening.
Phosphates, we all be dead.
That happen. Uh, we melt.
But this is one, this is a transition.
Metal goes to here. Now am I,
when I,
when I'm the metal and I have oxygen
here and then I say have an arm.
You can imagine my arm being double
bond without pie going like this.
And here on my belly,
I'm going to have and to Adam
in this disease and the like,
it should be red, you know, actually
didn't read, but he's going to,
he knows why I don't check for blood.
So you come like this and you
grab it and it pops off me.
I'm the, I'm the activated thing in
the middle and it goes on to there.
That's in a park side, three membered
ring. And if I attack it with a backhand,
I would get the opposite
result in terms of attack.
And that's, uh, that doesn't
happen because the geometry,
the transition states in the
projections of the center,
you can't get as close to a center
shot on this thing with the backend.
So that's why we're starting to explain,
we're going to explain a little bit more.
Mike's going to do some
acting later and you know,
you'll see a little bit more clearly
the topology of the situation.
But here, you know it's cool because
you get these templates like a Mandrel,
you grab hold of this oxygen atom,
which is [inaudible].
The metal Gra has lots of in the
orbitals is the d zero metal.
It activates the thing this way.
And then the orphan lone
pair of the homo attacks,
the backside and all this 20 business
goes on. But there's no mechanism.
It's a known mechanism transfer.
It's one of these like you draw a bunch
of arrows and everything happens sort of
in a smooth way.
No ions involved in unlike
sn two chemistry. Okay?
Slow step is then uh,
this footstep and then it comes off
and more stuff goes on. It goes around.
So that's the trick we played here.
The first idea was take advantage of,
of fixing the thing.
So once you fixed this,
this flat system that you want to make,
go pop up this way or that way.
Now you have a chance of doing it because
the thing you're transferring from can
recognize this kind of
situation from that one,
like it's part of the same
molecule temporarily. In fact,
this is a covalent bond right
there at this point. Too much.
I always say too much.
Okay. What's he going? Um,
then came great man from Japan.
He's now head professor at Kyoto Oshima.
He was fantastic.
Boiler room producer in titanium,
my husband Ian, you name it.
I think that was where all the
work was done for the Nobel prize.
It was done at MIT but
happened at Stanford just
because I was there for a few
years. But you know those early years in
your career when you do your work in the
boiler room or what produce you,
like your personality doesn't change
after your four years old, right?
Or three years old here pretty
much locked in. Unfortunately,
in some ways it's the vanadium system and
we put on this Carl machinery here and
it gave us 80% [inaudible] that
means an antiemetic access was,
it was a 90% when item or an anthem or
the right hand say and 10% the other,
and this looks good,
but it only works for that one substrate
and all the others types with it.
You can have like methyls there are
methyl there and you get nothing.
It's so you have to get everything
customize. This login is,
you've got to get the right leg in there
and that's what you expect with nature.
We're taught by a meal,
Fisher and the lock and key
nature is supposed to be very,
very touchy about changing
your, her preferences. And
that was what we expected.
Why didn't expect that?
I expected that.
This type of all of and and this type
with something that all of these would
need class of catalyst about
six shapes of all ovens.
So that's what my dream was to get maybe
six catalysts cause we didn't have the
paraphernalia.
The nature has all around.
Well for years, we tried 10
years, we didn't get anything.
It was always this game of
like almost no reliability.
And then when we came to titanium, we've
been working with vanadium molybdenum.
We came over to titanium I and we,
and we put in tartaric acid ester one
day, this was me, it was got Suki,
he should have gotten a Nobel price with
me because this will use half of this.
I pick the right metal at that
time and the right system,
but he's the one who
picked the right Ligon.
And let's go onto the next.
You'll see this is tartaric acid.
This is so called natural. It comes
from grapes, it's the cream of tartar.
When you protonate it becomes third
target acid over here is the unnatural,
but there's a plant in Africa,
but he articulated that has about,
it's a huge area around the Sahara.
So there's maybe more of that nature,
so-called unnatural
than there is a natural,
you know the story about tartaric acid
that goes way back to Louie pastor.
His discovery of tetrahedral carbon,
I mean Ben, the precursor to it.
Grapes,
very sexy looking things.
We always like humans seem to like to
drink them and eat them and look at,
uh, this is the famous recipe.
So that day, tight cut,
Suki took tartrate and
put it together with a,
Oh, I'm thinking, I forgot to say
something here. Yeah, just quickly.
Uh, maybe I don't have it. No,
it comes later. Okay. Put the TV.
HP was the kind of oxygen we'd always
been using. There's the titanium,
which comes from titanium dioxide
or titanium tetrachloride.
Everything that's white in this world.
All these, that's titanium dioxide.
It's only white pigment anybody ever uses.
Uh,
and so that's the team docs.
It's very insoluble,
but you can make it into this cycle.
The router's if you,
if you do the right chemistry,
and this is the wine acid.
We put it in dicer approval.
Tartrate traders and Esther.
And we kept getting 90% 100% 95.
Every Olson we put in that was in the
little like alcohol that had this handle
on. It gave Katsuya about week of this.
And we were just about dying, you know,
he said, I was looking at
him, he's looking at me. He
was, we didn't believe it,
you know, so we had to try to
kill this but was right. And uh,
so it meant that here we had
some new principal. We could,
we could actually just take one catalyst
and get them all almost to get them all,
but there had to be a little
cow calls. Um, so this is,
this is the famous recipe discovered,
uh,
I think in an October
day in 1980 at Stanford,
I'd already decided to go back to MIT.
I might not have decided to do
that if this had happened sooner.
We get depressed when our
researchers and working, I mean,
whether we don't show it or not, it's
the only thing that matters. Really.
A real killer research
guy who wants to put, see,
understand what makes nature
tick and whatever else.
If that's weren't going well, life
is good, otherwise nothing's could.
So I was going, I went
back to MIT, which is,
I wouldn't have if I had gotten this
about three months earlier probably.
And here we are,
there's Kazuki Sign Drinking Tarik Tarik
aqueous is about 5% aqueous tartaric
acid and wine and champagne. And this
was on the portrait, the Mudd building,
which was where our lab was on the top.
And what I'm going to show here is why
[inaudible] so important in a nutshell,
this is a really nice little substrate.
It has this type of alcohol,
stride substituted,
but you see the oil here,
there's no one, Ooh, over here.
This is a more reactive all of in
for the transfer of the oxygen,
but it doesn't have the handle.
So this is,
it ends up winning by a factor
of 200 in this system where they,
if oxidation requires the thing,
the bind and going into a molecular
and that's nice in its own right.
But to get we got and made
all the time of course,
because we have no face selection.
So here we and titanium goes about
10 times faster with tartrate.
When you add it, this does
something to make every other metal.
The years before Oshu might taken vanadium
and Molybdenum, which are the best,
uh, for isolated double bonds, but
you put tar trade in, he kills him.
So my instinct think would not
have been titrated. And again,
this is the kind of thing, everything in
science, the rules change all the time.
You wake up in the morning,
you should iterate your
favorite desire every morning.
It's going to look different to you
in the shower and you can never, they,
that was eight atomic bomb was
made by theoretical geniuses,
but the guys who did it actually found
they had aluminum foil on the source.
They kept it on there for about a
year or two. Some guy said, man,
I think we need this. What about if we
take it off? That was the answer. I mean,
these guys are like us. They just
try this, try that in the law, right?
That's what gets really
things done in this world.
The theories are all are important.
Nobody would even think about trying
to without the theory. But uh,
okay man.
In California just when the oil parts
from mixing pain and why that's what they
said in the,
in the La Times who sort of true to them.
Dockside tartaric acid and
there's the [inaudible].
I like my students to know where the
mother earth is and I like things to be
cheap. I don't like to
be far away from, uh,
river that strong or a power
source or in this case,
this is tartaric acid.
It comes in a 100 pound bags.
This is Spanish tartar and that's,
this is Victor Martinez,
who's one of the heroes in this
chemistry from the Canary Islands.
This comes to Pfizer.
They make things out of it,
but it comes in ships and a hundred
pound bags and we still have that in our
stock room somewhere.
That's uh,
there's my daughter celebrating the
synthesis of the unnatural sugars by this
method and uh, I got
the wrong one, didn't I?
I threw out the wrong. Yeah. Anyway,
you're going to have to interpret.
This is the mirror image of
the picture that was taken,
I guess because you see the
name over here is backwards,
but she's looking at the El sugars.
These are the ones that we don't make.
There's eight of those exos and
these are the ones that, uh,
meal Fisher made in his famous work,
the best chemists who are live except for
event Hoff two was even better because
he did an organic cereal,
chemistry and physical chemistry.
And I think he was the greatest chemist
who ever lived, uh, than half of us.
But anyway, Fisher was better than
me, but he lived in this century.
And in terms of understanding
and arguments and rationale of,
of Sin Synthesis, and he made all
the, a lot of these sugars over here,
but this, this, this is Tito assembly at,
she's a photographer. My wife's friend,
it was just taken in 1983 was on the
cover of chemistry in Britain and, uh,
Hannah was seven. And
Anyway, Tito is, uh, uh,
was a friends when she took the picture.
And this book though is a huge book,
which was gotten by Nancy Shrock from
WHO's in charge of the MIT archives and
there's a book store and Nancy.
So here we've got Nancy Schrock this,
we've got Peter Symbaloo whose husbands,
Dan Mcfadden and won the Nobel
Prize in economics 10 years later.
And uh,
Dick won the Nobel prize a couple of
years ago and I want it in 2001 so the
picture is kind of connected and there's
Lewis Carroll of course looking glass
milk and Neil Fisher is a heavy
duty picture for me anyway.
Um,
there's Nexium and maybe we're getting,
I went too far into the other stuff and,
but here's the atom,
the Red Adam that's going to end up
being transferred onto the sofa. And,
and, and well,
Mike showed, told you that the dice
bravo mean, what would the role be?
I hope I can go to the board
now and show you a few things,
but this catalyst is exactly the recipe
and it makes billions of dollars a year,
this product, right. And,
but the pattern is Stanford
patent is no longer valid. It's,
it's run out, even though it
hadn't run out when they started,
but they didn't believe that this was an
infringing that patent actually in the
beginning. But nobody knew. University
Sue's companies. I can't afford to.
Sanford couldn't afford to Shirley. Yeah.
I don't think there's anything
else behind that. Is there
some light on the board? Is that
uh, yeah, that's, no, that's
funny. Yeah. Yeah. I don't really,
yeah, that's where I lose the structure.
Why don't we just come down a little bit?
Oh, we don't need this
structure, I don't think.
Well, no, I don't think
so. I think they can see,
do you remember the vanadium picture of,
I'll make it titanium now,
but there's this alcohol group and Ah,
okay.
And
on this we have this peroxide group
that's bound and it's bound database Lee
there. It's got this tertiary
butyl group here and,
and then the alcohol is bound here
and
oh,
it goes sort of that down.
Just try to show some of the steering
chemistry and then underneath it's coming.
Yeah, it's coming folded like
this underneath. So it's,
I can't draw very well,
but this is supposed to be coming with
its lone pairs is high bonds on the
backside of this bond. So we're
going to do an attack one there and,
and we'll break this bond will break.
We'll, we'll bring the lone pair here and,
and we get, we get the
approximate now. But the thing,
this is patent lawyers
can be very creative.
Like every fuel has creative
people and Yale are,
is connected to this fellow
Burt Roland and he was in the,
in Palo Alto at the time and the
company and he had just gotten famous.
So almost in famous because he,
that pattern was really aggressive.
This boiler Cohen Patent,
he wrote the boiler corn pattern.
He's related to Mike because he got
his phd with Bartlett at Harvard,
like liked it. So that's a
long time ago. That's a great,
great something relationship.
And then comes Weiberg cause here at Yale,
he was at Seattle then and he took p
postdoc. He decided he liked chemistry.
In principle, you're smart,
physical, organic chemists.
But he didn't like the lap.
He wasn't any good and alive.
And he didn't like to be there.
So he became a patent attorney,
did very well. And he,
he writes great patents. And so when
he, he read our paper, our first paper,
we gave him a little communication and in,
and then he got cut Suki and,
and uh,
me over to his office and we
interviewed us for about 10 minutes.
Next day we got a patent.
It never changed a word of it.
And I'll tell you why it's
creative I think on this is the,
were getting ready for the next few. But
I could tell you about that. If we don't,
we don't make it, it won't matter
that much. But here's the main, uh,
so this is going to be the oxygen and
they should be red. But we have pink here.
It goes this one, but that one doesn't
transfer. This is the one that transfers.
So what Roland said is you've got
a metal which can grab things.
Now the things that grabs, you know,
could be x, it could be so for,
or a mean group that could grab.
And then he just drew,
I think drew a carbon with no,
it could be any carbon and it didn't,
it didn't have to have just ch two and
then he drew this g and then he drew.
Yeah, I did draw an oxygen atom
here, I guess that was activated.
And so this oxygen, he didn't have
generality there. That was specific.
That was the only thing that was specific.
These two things.
So this could be any kind of own
peer and all often is a lone pair.
So for his own pair of Foster's as a lone
pair of nitrogen as long pier and and
sure enough when I read that I
said my God, this gives us idea.
So we started doing amino alcohol.
All these things work, you know.
So this is from Burt role on the
patent attorney. He's a co invent that.
He was a co inventor of those
other reactions. We never
brought any more patents.
It's a good thing.
Don't waste your time on patents.
They'll just not use them
until they expire. We never,
we made enough to go on a vacation
once a year in a car. Not Too far away.
Got Sued. Got Suki and I, you
know, we got people who got rich,
got most year,
one year we got $20,000 each or something.
That was a really sharp maximum from
the bag of bug gypsy moth traps this
parlor. But I okay.
Don't show the transfer.
I think maybe it'd be nice for us.
Mike and I show are what features
have to be over here in these ligands.
He,
you see the tartrate has this feature,
it grabs the titanium out front.
Let's try to put it out front here.
So the titanium is that here and down in
the back here you have this ester group
and up in the back over here
you have an ester group.
And I can't remember if
that's what we plan to do,
but out here on the front is coming
in the alcoholic, this g group,
and there's an oxygen that's hot over
here, the that can be transferred.
So Mike's going to put that,
uh, I'm going to put that on.
And you're the, Oh, is that
okay if you're the old,
maybe it's better if I'm the
old. Oh, no. Okay, I'll be,
I'll be the titanium.
So see,
I've got this oxygen that wants to go
off because it's a weak bond and uh,
I've got to get it over to him.
He's the low alcohol,
but we're going to pretend
you as not to bind to me.
We're just going to do the
straight out attack here and
yes, like that. Right. So I'm blocked
here, but I'm open in these quadrants.
Is that right? Boy, you're quick.
I don't. Okay. So I'm natural.
Okay, well wait a minute and also,
but I'm not like this. I'm like that.
You see I'm a three dimensional world
cause I'm tartaric acid say I'm sticking
out here. So one of the chiral object,
now my mirror image wants superimposed,
but he's, yeah, he's that
way. He's a trans all often
and it looks like an Egyptian
like, know, like anyway.
Yeah, you actually the double,
we don't have this quite right.
Can you didn't arm down here cause we
though of one's here and one's going this
way. Okay. You got to go
in that way. Okay. So yeah,
the ones who are in that way.
Okay. And yeah, that's good.
Okay. Cause I could go like I may
not. It's like this. I'm sorry. Yeah,
I got to go like that. I could go like
that. That's the mirror image. Okay.
Now I'm coming towards them.
Okay. When are you back?
Oh my gosh. I can't do it. Say, but yeah,
that's the other. You need the
other mirror image for that one.
So I come this way and again,
safety.
So now it has, you have to, yeah.
If he was a good yoga person,
can parameterize a little better
now when you put him that way.
He's one and Auntie Marie,
if you put them on the other way,
that's the other name. Simple. It's
really simple, isn't it? Thanks.
Bye.
Yeah,
he used to organize that 10 seconds
before we came over that you can see we
didn't have any red red ping pong balls.
It's good with velcro.
You can do it with velcro.
We did it once with velcro red balls.
Okay.
Now
back to the screen. I think
we're, oh no, not, no,
not back to the screen. Let's,
let's, let's leave it alone.
This is going to be a little
expert. Oh, there's a clean, yeah.
Now if you look at the structure of the
resort, I won't put all the bells
and whistles on it's uh, it's a, uh,
images all structure.
Ben Zimmer dissolve,
which has benzene ring two nitrogens.
It's a five member aromatic hetero cycle.
And uh,
so you have double bond and one h and uh,
I can't remember what's on the software.
Is it an aromatic ring or is there a
Benzos and aromatic vinzel thing? I think,
and he might look at this and say,
this doesn't look anything
like Burt Rowan's thing there.
Uh, cause he's, where's the word?
We're the anchor points that we needed.
The, the group that binds the metal.
We have the lone pairs.
All right. Two Lone pairs,
rabbit ears. And there, if
you put oxygen on one side,
it's the same story as before.
If it,
this is in flat to start with,
but now we have these pairs.
If you put something here, you get one
in anthem or put something in there,
you get the other.
So the idea was to try to get an argon.
Had done this,
uh, [inaudible] won the Nobel
prize I thought should have,
but he's in France and he,
he had done a lot of great work in
asymmetrically drug chemistry and he,
he took the titanium [inaudible] and he
found that he put a little water in it
and you did the right things
and wished I wasn't as general.
But you got a very good
asymmetric edition.
So titanium was already known to do this,
but they,
the feature that's important
here is the PKA of this.
Ben Zimmer is all is probably it.
I looked it up.
I think it's below that of an alcohol.
So that means it can go on the titanium
reversibly so you see the titanium has
alcohols or ligands like this or in this
can exchange so we can have that come
off in this and go on.
Yeah, for this Hetero Cycle
and the benzene rings down here and now
we have something like that and covalent
bond and we've got the software here
and we've,
we also have the alcohol.
So there's an equilibrium
where you could invoke that,
but this is not as easy to
probably do is then alcohol.
It's more encumbered and it's probably
kinetics are slower for this and off of
oxygen for the hydrogen
transfers that are needed.
So I hypothesize here that
what the diets of probe,
but the humanics pace we call dies
appropriately. [inaudible] mean is doing
this is such a hinder to mean
that it can't react with anything,
but it's good for getting protons so
it can't itself get at the oxygen,
which you would worry about it.
We'd make an an oxide and it
can't bind the titanium anyway.
Night titanium hates nitrogen. I mean
you can, if you have an oxygen around,
it'll spit it out as fast. Make your
head spin. I mean this thing is amazing,
the hating Heiter's titanium and it's
talking to but especially titanium,
so it's never going to get involved
with titanium. So what's it going to do?
Well remember when you are trying to get
chemistry going in a system like this,
there's a mean,
has enough pka power to pull this proton
and usually you can write a concerted
mechanism like let me raise some
of this and have some room here.
Well I shouldn't erase that.
I'll go over here. You got
and spins him in his zone
where the soul for here,
and I'm going to put it
the hydrogen up here,
whenever you engage compounds
in Riyadh in a reaction,
acid base reactions, you look for
the basic sites in the acidic sites,
there's the acidic site. You might
think that's where the titanium goes,
but usually the mechanism for these
directions involves simultaneous loss of
this proton and attack here. This is the,
this is the place you're going to tack,
so you'll be attacking the titanium here
and the you got to get some help from
you going to get a lot of help
from this to mean cause you can,
you can put it someplace,
just take it right off and you'll have
some of that ammonium soul around to a
little bit transient and this
will help you because you need to,
you need to
move things around.
That's why this reaction was not good.
Without that I mean it,
you need the scramble was system and
keep it rolling so that the things get on
and off.
That's ketalysis often has
this like there's six maybe
there's always a loop and
if you look at any catalytic cycle,
there'll be usually one step that's
really bad news until you get it fixed.
And that step is where controls the rate.
She gets steady state the slowest step.
This is a democracy,
get dialysis you, there's no set
that's more important than any other.
The catalyst goes from each step. The
tight team is moving through those cycles.
If there's a slow step,
there's 99.9% of the titaniums that you
need stuck before this one mountain that
goes way up. Like Mount Everest.
You got to drop that one down.
If you get that one down,
the rate goes way up.
If you get them all the same height, you
really roll. And that's her secret rule.
The turnover limiting step is everything
and you could tell us is in a lot of
times the turnover
limiting step is so high,
they don't even know there is ketalysis.
If you can break that,
you'll find a world of ketosis.
It didn't exist before,
so that's what I think is
exciting about Catholicism.
It's alive as long as you have some energy
to dissipate your, that's life itself.
So here's what, then I've finished
this quickly off without any details.
You can see what I'm going to do here.
It's just that that I acted that hot
oxygen atom that that's activated,
the transfer, this is the handle.
That would be the look alcohol.
So it's dead ringer for, for for the
cuts. Rupee for the Burt Roland Patent.
Right. That's, that's what I
think. And, uh, the mean. Yeah,
three me make sense here too.
And uh, I guess it's that,
well, Sanford may love, we,
they brought over 10 people from research
and they brought over three lawyers
from Astrazeneca because Stanford thought
maybe should get something out of this.
And I told the story like this and they,
they didn't,
they pretended that didn't make
any sense at all. You know,
and it was pretty unsatisfying.
But Rowan was there,
I don't know if he's still alive. He
had cancer then, but so we didn't,
but they'd already made $6 billion
because the catalyst pattern was the only
extent patent, but it did have this
feature in it. And so they write in them,
I think they right in the face of the
patent, but they didn't like that. And,
and you know, that Stanford
wasn't going to pursue. Uh,
and the other thing we talk,
I like to mention is they invited me over.
This was before this
meeting about the patent.
I guess I started to notice the old team
chemistry and Kazuki and I taught and
we agreed that maybe we should
raise our hand. But before that,
what happened was I got invited to go to
a hotel in Munich, the fanciest hotel,
and they put me in this
big room up the stairs.
They wanted me to say something about
right and left hand and medicines and I
blow 15 minute spot,
1000 or 1200 gastroenterologists from,
from uh,
Germany won't.
And they were doing the story about how
important drugs had to be optically pure
and that,
that story doesn't wash too well here.
And I didn't realize it was going,
but I,
I went and I did my part and I, I, I,
it is true that many drugs are toxic in
one form and good in the other and, uh,
was able to make those points.
But what happens here is,
oh, and I also, they gave me this
suite on the top that had like a,
a stare at spiral staircase to the bed
at the very top of Madonna had stayed
there the week before.
That's okay for her.
She doesn't have a prostate problem. Hey
Yo, I hated that place. I had become,
the h had had a fire pole so I could get
down to the bathroom. Anyway, I, yeah,
well what happens is as Mike told you,
you got,
you just look at the facts and that system
and I noticed them just the day I was
sitting there in the audience and the
press was interviewing us and I wish we
did to the guy next to me. He looked at
me and frown. It was about the weights.
All right.
I mean the rest of mate 20 milligrams
and optically pure and I think the uptick
impure is substantially more reactive
in this case because he gets in better.
It's of course just the
pro drug for the thing.
But the thing that was missing
from the experiments is the,
is the 40 milligrams of resume,
which we'd give them equivalent
against the one in anthem or of the,
of the 20 milligrams of pure. And
that was missing. They doubled the,
and it was just the sore thumb there
for me. But I didn't say anything.
Nobody asked me. Fortunately prayers, if
they had, I would have said something.
Right. I imagine you, that's
the way we are. Right.
And Mike like this and he smiles be,
he gets the,
he gets the hard evidence, uh, in the
middle of your talk. Sometimes he does it,
but it's, for me, it's the
best thing you can get.
If you can get killed by a friend,
it's the best way to get killed.
Anyway, I'm finished. That's it. Yeah.
Yeah.
You're welcome.
We maybe have time for
one question or solve.
Where are we getting back to our
normal business? Anybody? Sharpless
no, thanks again. You, yeah, you're
welcome. And I'll have a good trip back.
I'll get that stuff to you through Scott.
Okay. Okay, good. Yeah, that's mine.
What's yours here is this, is this unit?
Well, I can give that Scott's, yeah,
I'll give it back to Scott.
Okay. Thanks so much. Good luck.
[inaudible]
okay.
Back to our routine now.
Yeah, I'll be, I'll be back
there. Yeah, I'll bring it to you.
Okay.
A,
Oh,
he forgot to show this picture.
There he is with the royalty of Sweden,
his,
his wife.
And the other Nobel
laureates in chemistry.
Okay.
And he was going to talk about Carbone
too. He wanted you to smell it.
I told him you had smelled it, but he
had an idea for a novel based on Carbone,
which he didn't have time to get to.
Okay.
So we were talking about the uh,
con formation of rings and we talked
last time a lot about cyclohexane,
uh, and the, and how it distorted.
Remember that it's not really ideal with
the axial bonds parallel to the axis,
they spread out a little bit.
The ring flattens a little bit to minimize
the energy as calculated by molecular
mechanics. Now how about in
a four membered ring instead
of a six membered ring?
Well,
if we look at the what molecular mechanic,
he says about the source
of strain in this system,
you can see that the big
contributors are bend. That's what,
uh, that's what buyer had already talked
about, about the ring strain, right?
Having 90 degree angles
is not going to be good.
So that's caused costing 13 and a half
kilocalories per mole and torsion.
Because why is,
why is there such high torsional energy,
15 kilocalories from all almost.
What's the source of that?
Anybody see
as you go around the ring,
everything is exactly eclipsed.
Everybody see that every carbon
carbon bond is eclipsed. Right?
So that in molecular mechanics sums up
to almost 15 kilocalories per mole. Now,
if you were,
how would you try to minimize the energy?
Is this probably the lowest energy form
or can you think of changing it so that
it'll be lower?
Any ideas,
Kevin?
Yeah, if you make it, not exactly eclipse.
If you make it a little
bit towards scatter towards
staggered by twisting about
the bonds that will lower
that 15 kilocalories per mole.
But can you see what happens if you
begin to twist around the bonds?
It sharpens the angles even more from
90 degrees to a smaller than 90 degrees.
So here's what happens when you do it.
The bending energy goes up by two
and a half kilocalories per mole.
Right?
But the tortional energy goes down by
three and a half kilocalories per mole.
Right? If you don't bend it too far. Okay.
And the other things stay
pretty much the same.
So this is a competition between
torsion energy and bending energy,
and the minimum is reached
with a little bit of of uh,
bending in order to relieve
some of that torsion.
Now how about if you had
a five membered ring?
Now you notice you have notice the
bending energy isn't bad because as buyer
pointed out, a Pentagon or regular
pedigree, John has just the right angles,
109 and a half degrees about right?
So there's hardly any bending,
but there's still a lot of torsion
from the eclipsing of the carbons.
So what you do if you run the molecular
mechanics program is to increase because
bending energy to incur to occur,
that is sharpen the angles a little bit,
right? But you get rid of a lot
of tortional energy by doing that.
And this particular conformation,
which you can see how
it's bent down at the car,
the black carbon eight there is
sometimes referred to as the envelope
confirmation of cyclopentane.
See how it looks like the fold of the,
of the envelope bent down.
Okay.
So there again is a competition
between bending and torsion.
Now,
like plastic models,
molecular mechanics is
satisfying because it says, uh,
not only what the structure should be,
but why,
what is it that makes the
energy the way it is? Okay,
so you remember last time we passed around
the cyclohexane and remember how they
clicked to go from one form to another.
So what's happening?
The question is what's the source of the
barrier to the cyclohexane ring flip.
So here's the chair cyclohexane
and when the ring starts to flip,
I remember first you go toward a boat
by bending one of those carbons up like
that.
Now what do you think the source of the
energy is that makes this hard to do?
Why do you go to a maximum
energy as you do this?
And then it clicks and it goes down again,
Sherwin,
uh, w w torsion. Now that's a good point.
There are in fact two bonds to
butanes that become eclipsed,
right? Both of the ones on the
right, this one is eclipsed,
but also this one is eclipsed those four,
right?
And indeed that worth about seven
kilocalories per mole of going uphill.
But there's an interesting point.
You did this with the models, right?
And you felt that click where?
How does,
how do those models,
those plastic models? No,
from tortional energy.
You see what I mean?
If you take ethane in
those models and spin it,
it spins completely freely. There's
nothing in the model. You could make it,
you could make the,
the thing that goes into the tube and
the tube a little bit triangular so that
as you tried to twist, it would go up
and energy and then down again. Right?
You see how you could do that in a model,
but that's not the way those are made.
Their cylinders, they rotate
freely. So why did the model click?
Pardon me?
Bending up what?
Yeah, right. Exactly. Look at this.
Why does the plastic model click?
Because when you're halfway across,
it's become,
if it were a heck if it were flat,
if the whole ring, we're flat,
what would the carbon carbon, carbon
angles be? If the ring were flat?
Sam,
if you're in a regular hexagon,
what's the angle,
Dana?
Yeah,
you gotta be careful holding your hand up,
even if it's just a scratch your face.
Yeah.
What's the angle in a,
in a regular hexagon hundred 20 degrees
wants to be 109 so it has to stretch out
if it becomes flat and even when
it becomes only partly flat, right?
This part of it is flat.
This one's out of the plane.
But that means in order
to have this one in there,
this bond gets compressed,
right?
Because if these angles want to
be 109 instead of 120 everything,
these are going to move this one and
this one will move closer together.
So these are in the trans,
in the, in this form,
when it's half planer,
this,
these angles are bent out and that angle
has bent in. So it's the angle bending,
which in fact does,
it does stress those plastic
models which causes it to click.
So it's interesting to be able to look
at models or at these calculations of
molecules as springs and see
if why various things occur.
So our molecular mechanics
programs useful. Yes, definitely.
They're useful.
Are they true?
No. Okay, so we'll go
on from there next time.